I'm going to show you how people do lie
and but it's going to be a very it's a
beginning of a project so according to
the definition of what is talks will be
about it can be from any stage of
project advanced or something that of a
beginning so this is going to be a
beginning of an exciting project
learning to lie and it's my work and I'm
a PhD student here in the University of
Michigan in the Ross School of Business
in the marketing department and I'm
working with Fred Feinberg who is a
professor in the department and
Elizabeth Burke from is our from
sociology and also from Dan with Dan
Ariely he's in Duke and he is a
behavioral economics professor so this
project is based on my observation of a
very interesting data set some of you
may have heard that there is an affair
seeking website there are actually some
of them a fairy seeking online dating
websites the people that want to have an
extramarital affair are logging in and
are joining the website to find an
affair
now it might be quite surprising but
there are such websites and I was pretty
shocked to find out about it when I just
came here as a student and I was
pregnant and I was very naive and then I
heard about it now thankfully I heard
about it just because you were fortunate
to have a huge amount of data that were
given to us and to work with so it's all
with the calibration of the website and
we received generously approximately 1
million profiles and activities of all
the active users on the website by
activities I mean chats messages
searches on the website and also profile
and profile changes now just technically
a are we accepting questions during or
after ok so I can accept questions
whenever you have please ask and it can
you tell me like two minutes before and
so we have approximately 18 months of
observations and I chose to look at
those that I can see their full lifetime
on the website from the day they join
until on the end of my observations and
so this is approximately this one and
you
I am and some fun and quick facts
because I know it's a pretty sexy
literally data set is so some people are
pretty interested to see who are they
these people that are actually logging
in to find an affair and I'm moving here
so that the camera can catch me and so
not all users are surprisingly consider
themselves as attached to whatever that
may be actually almost a third of them
is our sync declaring themselves to be
single 67% of them are women and 33% of
them are men and it is a pretty we have
a selection bias here because we got
from the company only those that have
paid there are active members and men
needed to pay and women did not so we
have some kind of selection there but we
can overcome this if we do some tools
and but what we also know that some of
these people are looking for a long-term
affair some of them are looking for an
online affair so this kind of d'affaires
some off lines and online some long-term
some short-term online affair the
average age is approximately 40 but
surprisingly as you can see here in the
plot surprisingly many people are either
37 or 45 you can see this jumps here
which kind of make me suspicious about
their honesty on the website and that
kind of raises the question of do are
they actually honest now I don't know
who of you are on an online web dating
website but usually the legitimate
website will kind of control for changes
as such and but there can still be
deceptions and research have shown the
Turks and be multiple reasons for why
people would lie on such websites so we
have decided to get into that since we
observe what they're looking for we can
actually try to understand and reveal
the reasons for their deception or lying
on the website the honest the honest
truth is that we don't know what the
honest profile is some people lie or
some people are becoming more honest yes
that is correct that is correct yes so
we're not trying to learn about the
honesty we don't try to kind of learn
because we don't know how the truth is
however we do have a survey that was run
on random sample of the population of
the users on the website in order to
verify some of the findings that we see
here so they are generally surprisingly
honest but they do change their profile
throughout time and this is where we're
heading to so approximately one hundred
twelve thousand people changed their
their profile items at least once now
what do I mean by profile items there is
this initial profile that is pretty hard
to see here but that includes their date
of birth there are limits what they're
looking for online or offline affair etc
a height weight body type ethnicity and
greeting which can which must be
included and is a greeting a textual
analysis and location which can also
change so some of this can technically
change you can reduce your weight you
can change your body type if you are
going to the gym now but some of these
things like date of births cannot change
ethnicity usually cannot change and
height after the age of 18 which is the
limits the minimum limit cannot usually
change so 43,000 users change this one
of these three items that are immutable
ethnicity date of birth or height and
this is something that is of interest to
us but all of these types of changes are
actually kind of interesting but why did
they change so there can be multiple
reasons and we are trying to reveal
those if we're trying to list so this as
I said it's an initial part of this
project so we try to analyze it based on
whether they're single or attached
whatever they define it as attached and
we see that there is some differences
here so this is conditional on changing
one of these three items how do they
kind of change different type of item or
the other so 52% of the users that have
checked that are single hand that have
changed their profile item have changed
their date of birth comparing to those
that are attached I don't know why this
is the case but we can perhaps shed
light on that more of those that have
changed that our single chains are
higher than those that are
attached and with women we don't see
much of a difference so you see here
that it's almost the same I don't know
why yet and it might not ever be
revealed but this is some descriptive
that we have initially started so if you
have any suggestions I'll be happy to
hear other things that we've looked into
are they different like the
differentiation between cyber affair and
long-term affair there are many there
are for more definitions of what they're
looking for but it's kind of ambiguous
in the definition so in just to
illustrate the differences I put this to
a cyber affair is something that you
probably will never meet this other
person so people there are sometimes
changing their height because no one
will ever see them and they change their
height more than those that are seeking
for something that is a long-term affair
where they might actually meet that
person and will be revealed to be two
feet less okay any questions so far
okay you're all shocked to hear that
people lie right I'll stand here okay
I'll talk with this one okay so um I
wanted to see if there are actually
differences in the value of changes that
people have so this is the percent
change conditional on changing any AI
any date of birth so conditional percent
change in date of birth now there is no
percent change it worse so it's at least
the age divided by the average age of
that population that have changed and
you see that people that are looking for
a cyber affair have actually have bigger
magnitude of changes so I'm dividing it
to positive changes and negative changes
and it seems to be that they're more
extreme and they're changes this is just
the average so there should be more
analysis here but for this short
presentation this is what can be
digestible I guess and similarly we can
see that the percent change in height is
also more extreme at least in some of
the membership age and I'll explain what
that is in a second for those that are
seeking an online affair versus those
that are looking for something long-term
and so remember sheep age is something
that is important to understand because
people are more active initially and
some of them survive on the website
longer and some are not and this can
also be a reason for them and and one of
the question that we want to see and
this is why optimizing is
part of the title of this talk is that
we want to see if people are optimizing
thank you their profile based on their
experience on the website if they learn
that one profile is more attractive than
another profile that they want to have
for themselves they might actually
change the website try to optimize
themselves as the product in order to
attract more searches and more messages
on the website and this is where we're
heading to now just out of curiosity I
check to see if people are differing in
their gender and to see if they because
the research suggests that men want to
be taller and that women want to be
younger but I didn't find at least in
the raw data didn't find any such
differences okay so this is the change
in date of birth and change in height
and no such and also change in weight
here and no such no not so much of it
it's definitely not significant
differences but not so big as well and
so these are the next steps I measure
this of success to profile changes if
they change this profile in one way over
the other are they actually succeeding
in getting more attraction or getting
more successful correspondences and do
they actually do it intentionally do
they optimize so they try do they learn
how to optimize their profile and and
perhaps shedding light on other possible
reasons for profile changes given this
specific setting do people change their
profile based on their type of affair do
they disguise themselves do they have
kind of wishful thinking perhaps they
want to reduce weight and they are
hoping to be lighter by the time they
meet this attractive person and and does
this actually do they change their
behavior based on their disguise so if
they're getting younger are they
actually talking younger or whatever
that is going to be more challenging
tasks but perhaps we can go there as
well so and if you have any comments any
questions I'll be happy to hear no I
don't know if we have time but also
after ok and this is my email and my
Twitter handle if you want to
communicate later can I ask can I get
questions ok yes
that's a great question so actually the
data that we got is from the company and
we know that these are active users they
have not given us the bots as far as we
know and the data as far as I looked
into our okay now it might be the case
that some of the users have not really
intended to have an affair and have
logged into the website and even join
and even paid to do something else but
this is not something that I'm going to
analyze however you're correct that some
of the reasons that the Social Sciences
show and one of the main researchers is
sitting right here in the School of
Information you call Allison and she's
showing that some people are kind of
scared that some people will be bots or
maybe not bots but some people that are
not intending to do good and therefore
they're disguising themselves to protect
themselves so that is a great point yes
so they actually wanted to so the
question was what is the motivation of
the company to share this data and so
the researchers that I'm working on our
pretty highly known and they wanted to
be collaborating with these people
especially dan Ariely and Elizabeth
Brooke and Fred Feinberg my advisor I
just jumped in as a PhD student yay and
but they wanted to learn about the
affair seekers nature and to learn about
this kind of phenomena what is going on
on their website so they wanted to take
advantage of the tool that marketing
research and social science research can
give to learn more about their own own
customers yes
it's all anonymize data we don't have
any emails any nicknames any names that
have ever been used so they removed it
they worked hard to give us a very very
high line on mice data yes so I think
presenting our next speaker this is the
other Kruger and she's gonna be telling
you about something that's even darker
than the dark life which is scraping you
of public salary information yeah hi so
thank you for the introduction I'm
excited to be here my name is EULA Kouga
and I'm working on a project where I'm
scraping an online database of salary
data and just to give you an idea of how
that came to be on the one hand I'm a
political scientist by training and I've
been using our since 2009 and this year
I started teaching myself Python because
I was really interested in using it to
scrape data and get more data from the
web and then I was looking for a project
where I could kind of apply my skills
and keep practicing and in the process
of that I came across the UM salary
database and searching it I felt like
that would actually be quite interesting
to explore because there's a lot of
research on why there's a pay gap
between men and women based on for
example that women are not socialized to
ask for raises or not negotiate their
first salary and so I was interested of
actually at the University of Michigan
there was such a pay gap if we look at
the data and I don't know how many of
you are familiar with this website all
right and how many of you work at the
University I work at the University - I
have to disclaim though that this is not
a project that I'm doing as part of the
University I'm doing this in my free
time and I've actually since I started
this project heard also that there have
been initiatives for diversity and
equity where the base had suggested to
have these comparisons made and
sometimes the the leaders of these
initiatives were not very interested in
pursuing these goals further so I still
don't know if I'm ever going to get into
trouble for working on this project and
presenting on it
so I was interested in scraping this
database and as you can see you can
search it and you always have like a
list of the recent searches so it's
never occurred to me
someone was looking at my salary but I
was looking up here so and I just
started scraping it by Department and
the good thing is when you scrape by the
patent you can also go by years so I can
get data also over time and so what I
did is I was using the selenium package
in Python to scrape this database and
then once I had scraped all the
departments and the information for
every person who works there and every
year I
I took out all the first names and
middle names and sent those to an API
that's called gender I see oh and and I
tried to get information on whether this
person is actually male or female and
once I had that data I started using our
tated so I was using ggplot and the DD
ridges package to start visualizing this
data so my goal for today was to come up
with some plots for you guys so I can
show you like the distributions of the
incomes by men and women um across the
university and so to the state I have 19
1950 departments scraped and I still
have some issues I don't have all the
departments on all the years because
unfortunately the human the Human
Resources office has has no like name
conventions so they sometimes change so
sometimes that departments were a few
years are missing because I automated
everything so I have to go back and kind
of like correct and also from the index
of this database which is actually not
run by the university it's a private
individual who's putting this online for
the public they also don't have a
complete index so I already realized
there are some departments missing so I
couldn't get those at the first run then
so then I have I I took it pulled out
about 1800 unique names first names and
middle names but when I sent those to
the IP I I was only I didn't able to
identify about two-thirds so I still
have about three three thousand seven
and fifty five individuals which I can't
tell if they're male or female it's just
because the university has really people
working from all over the world coming
from many different countries and even
though the API really covers a lot of
countries they just don't have all the
names so if you want to help me figure
out the refigure out the remaining ones
talk to me afterwards and I'll send you
some CSV files with for you to code by
hand
and I also want to say that in general
this has been a really entertaining
project because as I talk to people
people get interested lots of women are
really encouraging and and asked me to
send them some plots very soon and and
also I've gotten some really great
support from friends I don't want to
name anyone because in the end I want to
be the only one who gets into trouble
for this but if you've helped me and you
know who you are then thank you so much
so I just want to let you know that all
these results are very preliminary
because I still have a lot of missing
data I have years that I'm missing I
have departments that are missing so
whatever plots I show you don't take me
up on it don't quote me on it so are you
ready to see some perfect so let's look
at type of jobs so if you look at the
School of course like the direct like
the presence or is like one of the
highest people but then if you have the
deans you have the distributions by here
you can always see like the the blue
curve is the males and the red curve is
the females and then we can see it over
the years and so what you can see here
is actually that there's a pretty good
spread right so men and women are kind
of like covering the entire range and it
actually seems like it's more converging
towards towards equality in 2017 so so I
find that very encouraging because you
also see at the university that these
initiatives are kind of like moving
towards equity and so I think that's
actually quite a bit like a starting to
flatten out right like for the last
fiscal yeah
yeah this is my year yes yeah you seeing
this every year all the end of the
jewels who are working and it's not a
lot of genes at the school either so I
mean you have to take these data with a
grain of salt and also and I still have
to calculate some statistics to help us
like tell if these distributions are
different and I mean it's really just
very preliminary at this point yep this
is just the deans yeah so I have like
many different job titles yeah so here
you can look at all the full professors
where you can see that there does seem
to be a case where like there's a lot of
female professors kind of like training
towards the left right left side right
and lots of mail for this is kind of
like training towards the right side so
that does seem to be a little bit of a
difference because the distributor's
aren't like completely overlapping right
and also I have though still some
problems with like identifying everybody
who's in my senses um so here are the
associate professors so I've just had
them by different job titles and so here
you can also see that like over the
years the distributions are kind of like
starting to map each other more right so
I think that's quite encouraging because
it would also kind of like tell us that
if there is any initiatives to kind of
try to adjust salaries to be all more
equal than that would be going in the
right direction and assistant professors
you can still you can kind of see the
same trends I believe but but still I I
want to take everything with a grain of
salt because these data are not like
done at this point here are all the
directors and again I find that like
visually if we look at it it seems like
there are still a bit of a difference
right like it's not like completely
overlapping but it may be going in that
and then also for example an example for
research area specialists you can see
that these distributions actually are
starting to kind of like converge onto
the same into the same shapes but let's
look a little bit at departments and
units because there may be differences
by particular disciplines or depending
with someone as faculty or staff so what
I found we um interesting is for example
in the history department the faculty
the distributions are really overlapping
so there seems to be a lot of equality
which is I think again it's a very
positive appearance and and the same
seems to be on the law faculty so and
you can actually see that in the
beginning it seems to be more different
right like I'm like more than ten years
ago but then slowly but surely the
distributions are starting to really map
each other and similar for example and
emergency medicine you're also seeing
that the distributions are kind of like
starting to really like trace each other
similarly here so there's a lot of these
cases where I do see kind of these
trends where they're starting kind of
come closer together which would be
great for HR right because it's kind of
like moving in the directions where we
would try to come out get over this
gender gap that we've seen unlike
earlier years but then also um there's
and again here like it's the same right
like we used to have like a lot of men
who were making more but no slowly the
Moumen are catching up and like moving
in that direction so these are kind of
like those graphs where we always kind
of see the same but and this is for
example computer science and engineering
I thought I'd share that because it's
probably interesting to you guys where
it seems to be kind of similar and
actually also quite a few women at the
end who are also we're also having
higher salaries yeah I would think that
this is probably like either like a full
professor or maybe a chair and I don't
know why they left I would have to look
into like yeah yeah yeah you sometimes
see that chairs once I saw that a chair
was like going to a dean's office for
years and for two years they had like a
really extraordinary salary and then it
went back to normal so you do see these
changes sometimes yeah that's also
interesting like in women's studies
either I'm not able to identify a man
and for the past two years or they just
left the department but also in this
case actually the men were making less
maybe that's why they left and then we
have also also a lot of M departments
where actually there's still a gender
gap or there seems to be what I found is
blue wave that would not be so desirable
because we are seeing how men are kind
of like moving outward and women are not
really following behind so there's a lot
of these examples as well that I want to
share with you for example in a library
or in aerospace engineering where
there's a lot like quite a few men who
are still making a lot of salaries
whereas women are like a concern a lower
rate what I understand is the Botanical
Gardens they're actually starting to
move farther away from each other so
they used to be the same and now
suddenly the men are kind of taken off
and the women are staying behind
dermatology health management and policy
kind of the same the same trend the
Benefits Office and also no missing
gender info so there is not much that we
can still do to correct fungus other
than a policy change I guess the isodd
director's office and Institute for
Social Research the dean's office and
the literature science and the arts
college that's also staff or a
mathematics faculty there seems to be
like it's less severe than another in
other departments I guess or physics
kind of like the same trend Ross School
of Business there also seems to be a
case where now some men are starting to
make more money and the women kind of
still have to follow suit disclose
information which is like a big data
science school also seems to have this
trend and I saw a similar trend with
staff School of Nursing which I found
really interesting because you would
think that a lot of women work in the
same area and so just to give you some
ideas if you have a department you want
to look at come to me I really have
liked most of them here if there's
sufficient men and women to compare em I
could show you and what I want
moving forward as I want to improve my
data obviously I want to get all the
information on all the individuals who I
wasn't still yet able to classify as man
or woman and also I have to work keep
working on my faculty and staff
distinction to really figure out which
which jobs
apart from professors and some
instructors are also counted as faculty
by human resources and I want to do some
statistical comparisons of the
distributions and actually maybe like
make a rank from like worst to best and
stuff like that kind of like look better
into my data and I was interested also
and may be comparing job titles more by
school than just by departments I was
also interested in there's a difference
in the salary increases like percentage
of by every year and between men and
women and also perhaps account for total
numbers at the institution because I can
actually give everyone a unique
identifier and then follow them through
the university and so account for how
long they've been working at U of them
and perhaps also explore how they're
moving through your firm maybe it's a
good strategy to just keep applying to
different units and that way kind of
like increase your income and maybe
that's a way to deal with dual
appointments or someone suggested to
look at if Nissa t so if you have any
ideas for me come talk to me I'd be
excited to talk to you and yeah thank
you so much
[Applause]
nope it's I think it's um I think how it
works
I believe how I understand how I
understand works is that because the
university does publish these datasets
and after scraping someone actually told
me that I could have downloaded
spreadsheets from the library website
which I wasn't aware but I'll use that
to kind of like figure out how well my
scraper scraping drop they're in
comparison so someone just takes these
data and feeds them into his database
and makes it available to everyone but
but they do say in the frequently asked
questions that they are not affiliated
with the university did that answer your
question it kind of was both yeah it was
both like on the one hand I wanted to
just like apply my toolkit and kind of
expand on the other end I was really
interested in the topic and that seemed
like a topic that I would keep working
on out of interest yeah yeah
that's a really good question because in
general actually at the University you
see more women working there than men so
it's more like a 40 to 60% ratio and and
there's much many more women working in
staff positions and more than more men
actually working in faculty positions so
I do want to control for that in the
future two final speaker is Ryan feather
his talk will be about beauty the Beast
lesson some skill and I had a start up
okay thanks for the introduction so this
isn't going to be a very data e talk but
the lessons are ones that while working
in data science and software engineering
I found to be somewhat hard thought and
save a lot of time once you learn them
so if this is kind of relevant to where
you're working hopefully it'll be an
interesting talk for you so what I'm
going to tell you about is how we've
scaled our AI and our startup and a
little context what is that startup
first fuel software we're based in
Lexington Massachusetts and the problem
that we're basically working on is how
do you take the brain of someone who
might go into a building and try to
understand their energy usage and come
up with recommendations about how to
modify how to reduce that usage and we
want to put that into an algorithm so
that we can then take those sorts of
recommendations and apply them to
millions of buildings for our utility
customers and so I managed data science
and analytics engineering and I'll get
into why is it's a kind of a two-part
group as part of this talk so what is
the problem I'm talking about here
specifically right so you have some very
interesting hard math right so machine
learning or some statistics uh may I and
you want to take that and put it into
your product it's like your core IP
right that's you want to make it
scalable you want to make it robust how
do you do that
and I have a couple of insights maybe
some recommendations some thoughts about
like how you can actually manage that so
first when you think about McKinney
software problem or any structural
problem you want to think about the
human side of it first and a key
question for me whenever I think about
this like how am I gonna build a group
that does this is okay well how many
really good software engineers do you
know and if you're working in software
then hopefully you know quite a few
right and then if you think about how
many really good data scientists do you
know well if you're working in data
science or machine learning that sort of
research hopefully you know quite a few
of those too but then how many unicorns
do you know right how many people that
are truly excellent at doing both the
research and know all machine learning
and statistics whatever is relevant to
your problem and are really good at
software and really interested in
architecture and unit tests and all that
good stuff and probably not a huge
number right they're very hard to come
by
but you can't find some people that are
really interested in machine learning
data science know the lingo the basic
terminology can be conversant but how
many of you have some software
experience and can do things like write
a good API spec and think about what
process looks like and talk to your
software engineers so what I actually
think is a good mix is if you get maybe
one of these people like on the glue
person for maybe for us it's every three
data scientist for you you know your
mileage may vary and they can actually
Shepherd your data science your hard
algorithms into the product and I'll
talk about a little bit how you can use
your tools to help them do that too as
my second point
so when I think about tooling I could go
on we've thought about this a lot but
one kind of major point is just how do
you structure your project how do you
set things up so that people who are
good at data science can work on data
science and your software engineers can
do really good software engineering work
and this probably is a too controversial
to say hey you should have probably a
repository for your main product and
that can be where your core engineering
team does most of their work it's the
back-end and front-end maybe it'll be
Ruby or Java or whatever you like to
work in it's also probably not too big
of a stretch to say that maybe your data
science your analytics can be in their
own repository right and they're
probably going to want to work in our or
Python which I found works really well
for this purpose but this is where it
might get a little scary to some folks
and that I say actually do your data
science your research in the same
repository that you're going to put into
production and this actually works okay
if you take advantage of your tooling
and you have your kind of glue person
managing that flow so to give an example
if you're working on a good branch and
trying some new R&D ideas something
that's completely new and you want to
see if it works that's fine you're on a
git branch you can do whatever you want
you can modify whatever code and once
you've proven out your idea if you have
someone who's kind of on your team
managing the flow then you can do all
the good things like code review and you
know testing etc but you won't have to
worry about messing up your production
stack if you have nice things like that
in place right so that's where your glue
person really comes in handy the reason
I think this is actually a good flow and
I've worked in other flows before is
that if you think about the alternatives
well you could try taking you know your
your algorithm and translating it from
whatever the researcher did their R&D in
into something you're more comfortable
with for deployment like C or C++ or
Java or whatever the case might be
that's going to be really difficult for
an
reasons it's gonna take a lot of time
and maybe there are some scenarios where
this is the right choice but if you
think about well you have to do a full
translation of that code the software
engineers have to understand that code
really well or have to understand the
concepts really well to implement it
your data scientists are now no longer
going to have as much insight into the
final product they're not going to
necessarily understand the Java or the C
year to C++ as well and it's going to be
in some new format with lots of you know
nice software engineering practices so
that's actually not a really effective
approach in my opinion the other
approach I've seen done as you take the
code may be still in its native language
but you go and plunk it in some like
production repository hands off data
scientists can't even like touch it
anymore again now your data scientists
are no longer able to see what's going
on in the final product if you want to
iterate quickly and make changes then
they may not even know what the current
state of what you've deployed is so
again you know maybe not the most
effective especially if you're like us a
startup who's like exploring the
solution space and trying to improve so
that's that's basically my two main
recommendations get a get a glue person
on your team who knows a little bit of
both worlds and then used in the
Shepherd your data science algorithms
into your product and do it in the same
repository it'll be fine
Thanks
[Applause]
so the question is how easy is it to
define the glue person and it's not
extremely easy not as easy as finding a
software person but I would say like
we've hired a lot of data scientists
over the years and we've hired to glue
people I was the first one at my company
and then we hired another one and it's
doable it's about the same frequency
that you'd find a good data scientist
with I think dependent but the key is
like really write your job spec well
know what you're looking for don't
expect someone that's going to come in
and come up with your new deep learning
algorithm and do good software you just
need someone who you know has enough of
a math background and during your
interview you know that your data
scientist can talk to them decide it to
your question yeah interesting paths
didn't know what I wanted to do when I
grew up so I just did computer science
did some software engineering for a
couple of years I didn't want to do
something more interesting so I did a
master's and computer vision and I
actually ended up working in software
again but this time on implementing
software algorithms much in that kind of
translation type mode of operation and
then I found software I'd then I found
first few software and they were really
looking for someone to kind of fill that
niche and luckily they hired me
so with that I'd like to thank all three
of our speakers again both Ryan EULA and
Donna let's give them another round of
applause
[Applause]